البصل والبطاطا يشعلان الانتخابات التركيه
وشاكيرا تهاجم بيكي مجددا اخلص لنفسك اهلا
بكم الى تفاعلكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم منافسه محتدمه متوقعا تشهدها
انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه الاحد القادم
اربعه مرشحين تم اعتمادهم الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان وكمال كالجدار اوغلو
ومحرم انجي وسنان اونان وبينما تتجه
الانظار وتنشغل العقول في نتائج تلك
الانتخابات على الجانب الاخر تحتد
المنافسه بين مرشحين اثنين اردوغان
ومنافسه الابرز كالجدار اوغلو فحرب من
التصريحات والفيديوهات نشهدها بين
المرشحين وبين انصار كل منهما ويبدو ان
التسميه الاصح لتلك المنافسه هي حرب البصل
والبطاطا او ديمقراطيتهما فبينما يخاطب
اردوغان انصاره بالوعود التجاريه
والمشاريع الاستثماريه يخاطب منافسه
كالجدار اوغلو وانصاره بالبصل والبطاطا
والحياه المعيشيه في الاول يعد بانفتاح
على العالم وتطور اقتصادي ونمو تجاري
والاخر يعد الحياه المعيشيه وتخفيض
تكاليفها فاردوغان
ظهر منذ ايام بين انصارهم متحديا منافسه
ووافقا من شعبيته وقال لانصاره انه متاكد
انهم لن يبيعوه من اجل البطاطة والبصل
انقضت ايام حتى جاء الرد من انصار منافسه
الذين شاركوا الاخير فيديو كان قد نشره في
اتريل الماضي
ظهر خلاله وهو يتكلم عن السياسه
الاقتصاديه الهشه للرئيس اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه والتي اقمت البلاد في
ازمه اقتصاديه كبرى واستشهد في الفيديو
ببصله حقيقه الناس محتاره بين ان تختار
البصل والبطاطا ام الاسلحه والاست
ثمار
الحرب بين انصار كل من اردوغان وكل جدار
اوغلو تعدت مواقع التواصل وصلت الى ارض
الواقع فتعرض رئيس بلديه اسطنبول المعارض
اكرم امام اوغلو والذي يعتبر من داعمي
منافس اردوغان الابرز كمال كالجدار اوغلو
تعرض خلال خطاب مع تجمع لانصار اوغلو في
ولايه اردن الى رشق بالحجاره من قبل
مجهولين استطاعوا منعه من اكمال الخطاب
[موسيقى]
اما رده فعل بلديه اردوروم على ما حدث
فكانت باصدار بيان قالت فيه ان اكرم امام
اوغلو لم يخبرهم بانه قادم لالقاء خطاب
ضمن تجمع لانصاره وانما اخبرهم انه قادم
بجوله في الاسواق وللقاء تجاري هناك اما
سليمان صويلو وزير الداخليه فكتب في
تغريده ان اكرم امام اوغلو شخص استفزازي
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الدكتور سمير صالحه
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور سمير
اهلا بك معنا في تفاعلكم وفي العربيه
الملفت التوجه مرشح انتخابي كل جدار اوغلو
الخصم اللدود لاردوغان الى مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لشحن حمله تفاعليه ان صح
التعبير ضده مستغلا تصريحات مثيره للجده
الجديده هذه المره عن البصل والبطاطا كيف
تقيمون هذا التوجه
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا يعني اتفق
معك عامل السوشيال ميديا هذه المره سيكون
له تاثير مختلف عن المرات السابقه في
التعامل مع الانتخابات التركيه سواء كان
على مستوى الانتخابات البرلمانيه او
الرئاسيه لماذا لانه عامل الشباب كما يبدو
دخل بشكل مباشر على الخط يعني المحرك
الاول او الاساسي في السوشيال ميديا في
تركيا الان وبشكل عام ايضا هو الشباب
الذين تطرحوا اعمارهم بين 18 و 25 وهي
كتله بشريه مهمه الان في تركيا حوالي 12
مليون
في هذه الشريحه
يشكلون ثقل اساسي من ارقام الانتخابات
التركيه بشكل عام حوالي 64 مليون ناخب
سيذهب الى الصناديق يوم الاحد المقبل
بينهم هذه الشريحه التي تصل الى 12 و13
طيب مليون شخص 13 مليون وهذه الفئه الان
13 مليون ناخر من جيل الشباب او جيل زاد
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كما باتا
يعرف يعني من فئه 18 الى 25 سنه هؤلاء كما
قلتهم 13 مليون ناخذ في تركيا بينهم 6
ملايين ناخب يصوتون لاول مره في تركيا لاي
مدى هذا الجيل وهذه القاعده الانتخابيه
ستكون مفتاح الحسم وقد تقول للتغيير في
هذه الانتخابات
صحيح انا رايي الشخصي كما قلت لك قبل قليل
سيكون لها دور مهم اذا ما
ذهبت الى الصناديق لكن المشكله مع هذه
الشريحه انه قبل اشهر كانت تذهب بمنحان
المقاطعه الانتخابات عدم الذهاب الى
الانتخابات لاكثر من سبب يعني بين الاسباب
التي دفعتها في السابق الى اعتماد موقف من
هذا النوع هي عدم ثقتها بالاحزاب السياسيه
بالقيادات السياسيه انها ستعطيها ما تريد
من ضمانات في المرحله المقبله لكن يبدو لي
انه في الاسابيع الاخيره على ضوء ما
سمعناه في الحملات الانتخابيه وهذا وهذا
الشحن والتعبئه الميدانيه برايه سيدفع هذه
الشريحه للمشاركه في هذه العمليه
الانتخابيه لها مطالب كثيره اساسيه هذه
الفئه كيف سيتم التعامل معها في المرحله
المق انا اظن انه هذه الفئه ايضا نعم
قادره على التاثير في رسم
النتائج شئنا ام ابينا لماذا لانه كثير من
القيادات السياسيه والاحزاب وضعت في
برامجها في حملاتها الانتخابيه مسائل
باتجاه هذه الفئه بشكل مباشر بينها ضمانات
في مجال التعليم في موضوع العمل في موضوع
ضمانات اجتماعيه
وغيرها لذلك هذه المره برايي نعم هذه
الفئه تكون قلت في الفترات الماضيه هذه
الفئه كانت تتوجه نحو مقاطعه الانتخابات
احدث استطلاعات الراي في تركيا اوضحت ان
فئه الشباب الذين يحق لهم التصويت هذه
المره سيتوجهون للتصويت لصالح المعارضه ضد
حزب العداله والتنميه بسبب انهم ذاقوا
درعا من ارتفاع نسبه البطاله وصلت الى 24%
بين فئه الشباب من هذا العمر وكذلك تدهور
مستوى الوعيشه وذاق درعا من وعود الحكومه
كيف تنظر لهذا التوجه
نعم استطلاعات الراي الكثير من استطلاعات
الرايب
ذهبت باتجاهين كما قلت لك قبل قليل اما
انها ستقاطع الانتخابات واما انها ستذهب
باتجاه دعم مساله التغيير ترفع شعار
التغيير في تركيا مشكله هذه الشريحه الاهم
انه كما اشرت انت ايضا قبل قليل حوالي 6
ملايين شخص منهم سيذهب الى الصناديق للمره
الاولى انها لا تعرف الاحزاب الاحزاب
التركيه الاخرى غير حزب العداله والتنميه
لماذا الحزب العداله والتنميه في السلطه
منذ العام 2002 وهذه الفئه لم تختبر لم
تعايش احزاب سياسيه اخرى في السلطه لذلك
هي متمسكه بالتغيير بالتجديد بان ترى
احزاب بديله غير حزب العداله والتنميه هل
يكون لها ما تريد نقطه اولى نقطه ثانيه هل
يعني نذهب وراء استطلاعات الراي انه فئه
كبيره من هذا من عنصر الشباب ستذهب فعلا
وراء دعم التغيير ام لا هذه ايضا مساله
برايه مسائل احد او صباح الاثنين المقبل
سنعرف الكثير من الاجابات حولها طيب دكتور
بالرجوع الى تصريحات رئيس التركي باختصار
والمثيره للجلد دائما رجب طيب اردوغان الى
اين قد يتوجه بالفعل الناخب التركي نحو
البطاطا والبصل ام الاستثمار والاسلحه
البطاطا والبصل كما تعرفين انت ايضا جزء
من نقاشات الاقتصاد في داخل التركي من
ارقام المعيشه ارقام التضخم ارقام الغلاء
هذه المعادله اولى في كفه نقطه مهمه تشرين
اليها لكن بالمقابل في عنا في الكفه
الثانيه مساله المشاريع الاستراتيجيات
البود التي انجزها حزب العداله والتنميه
سواء كان في موضوع الطاقه في موضوع الغاز
في موضوع انجازات
حملت المسيرات وغيرها من المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه المهمه لذلك قرار الناخب
الان سيكون بين الكفتين يعني باتجاه
التغيير واتجاه التركيز على موضوع
الاقتصاد وارقام المعيشه وطال الاولويه ام
يعني الذهاب وراء الحكومه الحزب الحاكم في
الرهان على انه المشاريع الاستراتيجيه هي
اهم من ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
الدكتور سمير صالحه الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه شكرا دكتور
[موسيقى]
مشروب البودا او ما يسمى بعصير الغلابه
ومشروم مكون من الدقيق وبقايا الخبز
والشعير يضاف اليه الماء والسكر
والفانيليا وماء الورد يباع في الاسواق
المصريه من قبل باعه متجولين هناك المشروب
من اشهر المشروبات الشعبيه في مصر ومن يوم
الجمعه اسمه متصدر المنصات وجد الكبير
حوله السبب حالات تسمم اصابه ثلاثمائه
واثنين شخصا في محافظه قنا في مصر ما حدث
انه توافد الى ثلاثه مستشفيات محافظه قنا
اعداد من المصابين بدت عليهم اعراض التسمم
بسبب تناولهم مشروب البوضه من احد الباعه
في احد الاسواق هناك ومن بعد ان تم ابلاغ
السلطات المختصه من قبل المستشفيات عن تلك
الحالات شكلت النيابه العامه فريقا ليقوم
بالسؤال المصابين حول السبب اجتمعت
رواياتهم بشعورهم بالاعياء الشديد بعد
تناولهم المشروب من احد الباعه تمكنت
نيابه العامه من القبض على البائع وحبسه
لمده اربعه ايام على ذمه التحقيق بسبب
بيعه وتداوله مشروبات فاسده في اماكن غير
مستوفيه الاشتراطات للنظافه الصحيه وبسبب
عدم حصوله على رخصه من السلطات المختصه
لبيع المشروب ولابد مشاهدينا هنا ان ننوه
ان المشروب يتم بيعه في الاسواق من قبل
باعه متجولين وبالتالي من الصعب التاكد من
ترخيصهم ومراعاتهم للشروط الصحيه طبعا
المصابين غادروا المستشفيات بعد تحسن
حالتهم لكن الجدل حول المشروع لم ينتهي
والانقسام في وجهات النظر حوله سيد الموقف
جدل كبير وواسع تشهده بنصات التواصل في
لبنان من بعد نشر حساب السفاره الامريكيه
في لبنان صورا لتسارع مراحل بناء السفاره
الجديده في منطقه عوكر شمال بيروت مساحه
السفاره الجديده تبلغ نحو 90 الف متر مربع
من المباني ومئه متر مربع من المساحات
المكشوفه طبعا بلغت تكلفه بناء هذه
السفاره مليار دولار وتقوم ببنائها من
جديد بعد اربعين عاما على تفجير مبنى
السفاره القديم عام 83 حقيقه من وقت
انتشار الصور اصبحت الانتقادات عنوانا لها
واستهجن الكثير من اللبنانيين المساحه
الكبيره وضخامه المبنى في بلد صغير
المساحه مثل لبنان فهناك من اعتبر الصور
انها قاعده عسكريه تحت غطاء السفاره وهناك
من انتقد ازاله الغطاء النباتي من المنطقه
في سبيل بناء السفاره الامريكيه لكن ايضا
كانت هناك وجوهات نظر اخرى اعتبرت ان
المبنى الجديد للسفر الامريكيه يعبر عن ما
اعتبره علاقه متينه بين البلدان على كل
نناقش الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيروت صحفي
فاروق يعقوب اهلا بك يا فاروق اولا هذا
تفاعل لاستهجاني الكبير مع مساحه السفاره
الامريكيه الجديده في بيروت والبنيه
التحتيه وهيكليتها الى اي مدى هو مبرر
مرحبا اولا هذا الموضوع
المثير للجدل انه كل اللبنانيه بيعرفوا
هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع جديد علينا يعني
كل الناس بتعرف انه كان مبنى للسفاره
الامريكيه ببيروت عم يتعمر بمبنى كتير
كبير عم يتعمر بمنطقه عوكر واصلا هذا اللي
كان صار في مرحله قبل هذا المبنى كان
المبنى متاخد تقريبا يتعمر بمنطقه بعبده
حازميه غلطان وتم وتم اخذ قرار بناء هذا
المبنى بسبب قرب المنطقه لمنطقه المناطق
نفوز
حزب الله يعني هاي الضحيه الجنوبيه فتم
نقله رجع لمنطقه عوكر فهذا الموضوع كله
بيعرفوه من زمان يعني منو جديد لسه المثير
للجدل انه هو اول مره السفاره بتفرج عن
هذه الصور للمباني وهذا التوقيت اذا بدك
منه تفصيل يعني اجا اليوم جاي اليوم بالظل
بظل حكي عن تسويه بالمنطقه
لبنان بظل غياب للدور الامريكاني او للرا
يعني برايي كان واضح كتير جدا الرساله
اللي وجهتها السفر الامريكيه انه هي عم
بتعمر اكبر سفاره بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
بلبنان منو التفصيل صغير عم بتقول انه انا
هيدا البلد الي رايي فيه
ما بصير ما في كنتوا تخبطوني بهذا المحل
يعني اذا بدك بس انه هو هذا المبنى مبرر
اخر شيء هيدي السفاره يعني الامريكان
اشتروا الارض من قدام كل العالم يعني منو
شي مخبى وبعتقد كل اللي كلنا بنعرف انه
السفارات الامريكيه بدون مهمه بتنعمل بكل
الاماكن العالم حسب حجمها بس طبعا تتعامل
يعني بتعمر بتبني بطريقه
مراعي للشروط الامنيه كامله بتعمر مباني
محصنه بتعمر مباني كبيره هاي يعني وين
مكان معروف بهيدي الشروق معروفه هيدا
الموضوع لكن اللي صار بالبلد لا يعني في
فصيل بالبلد شوي مقفل السياسيا بسبب بسبب
سياساته وبسبب ما اوصل في البلاد اليوم من
من
الرداء المطلقه بالاقتصاد وبالسياسه لا
شيء يتسلى فيه بالبلد عبر عبر انه فتح
جدال حول موضوع حجم السفاره ودوره وسبب
دوره بالنهايه هذه السفاره موجوده ما
بعتقد اي راي من كل اللبنانيه راح ياثر
عليها للسفاره بوجوده
عندما نتحدث
عن بلد صغيره مثل لبنان لا تتجاوز مساحته
11 الف كيلو متر مربع تقام عليه سفاره
يعني مساحتها 210 الاف متر مربع هل
السفاره تحتاج لكل هذه المساحه في بلد
صغير وكل هذه المباني لتقوم بعملها اول
شيء اول شيء السفاره هي منها معموله
للبنان هي صعبه النقطه الارتكاز تبع
البناء لبنان
يعني لو الوضع يمكن اضبط بسوريا ما بعرف
اني حسب الامريكان كيف بشوفوا الموضوع
كانوا عمروها بسوريا وعمروها بغير محل بس
لا بلبنان لانه كمان ما ننسى نحن فعلا هي
السفاره حجمها مثير للجدل ومثير للتساؤل
يعني طبيعه الحال انه حجم بلد صغير هالقد
بده سفاره كبيره بطبيعه الحال لا ولكن هذه
السفاره طبعا لها دور سياسي بالمنطقه ودور
كبير وبعتقد اصلا في يعني بلبنان في في
قاضي عسكريه امريكيه موجوده بحمات كل
العالم بتعرفها كمان يعني منو السر هيدا
الموضوع موجودين قدام العالم بتطلع
الطيارات الامريكيه بتحمل وبتنزل وموجودين
وعندهم في في عسكر موجود يعني هذا كل
العالم تعرفوا منه مخبى هذا الموضوع
وبالنهايه كمان ما ننسى هي اقرب نقطه اقرب
نقطه نفوذج لروسي بالمنطقه بسوريا
هاي السفاره كمان منا تفصيل هيدا الموضوع
اخرت النهار هذا البلد لبنان مكان امن
لسفاره بهذا الحجم بعتقد يعني كانوا يعني
اكيد امان من باقي الدول براي الامريكان
انا يعني هذا تحليل منه مبني على اي وقائع
بس برايي بطبيعه الحال انه في ارض منا
معاديه هالقد للامركان مثل يعني
ينعمل هيدي وانعمل كمان
التفصيل بالمنطق بعيد عن دورها يعني اقرب
يعني الرساله من وراء ان تقوم السفاره
اليوم
الافراج عن هذه الصور المنطقه اللي عم
تتعمر فيها السفاره هي منطقه امنيه
بالكامل ما فيك تصوري ما في حدا يصور حتى
يعني اذا انت اذا عم تتجولي بسيارتي
بعربيتك بالسياره ما بتقدر تتجولي بدون ما
يطبوا عليك الامن ان كان الامن اللبناني
ولا الامن الامريكاني يعني
رصد موجود يعني حتى ما فيك تطلع درونز
تصوري من فوق الافراج عن هذه الصور من قبل
الامريكان بعيد اللحظه من قبل
هيدي الرساله السياسيه واضحه جدا اليوم
للاخرين نحن موجودين هذا البلد مش موجود
مش مضبوط انه احنا خارج اطار هذا البلد
احنا موجودين وعندنا راعي ما بيصير شي
بالبلد بيكون موافق عليه شكرا جزيلا من
بيروت يعقوب
فجر المرشح الديمقراطيه لرئاسه الامريكيه
روبرت كاندي قنبله من العيار الثقيل بخصوص
حادثه اغتيال عمه الرئيس الامريكي الراحل
جون كندي عام 63 حيث اتهم جهاز المخابرات
المركزيه بالتورط في اغتيال عمه
على تورطها في قتله واستشهد روبرت خلال
مقابله متلفزه له بكتاب جيم دوجلاس يصف ان
الكتاب هذا يجمع معظم الادله حول هذا
الموضوع كما وصف انكار دور وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه بانها تغطيه لمده ستين
عاما فعلى الرغم المرور 60 عاما على حادثه
الاغتيال واغلاق التحقيق الرسمي الامريكي
بهذه القضيه وتاكيد لجنه وارن التي تم
تشكيلها حينها للتحقيق بان هارفي ازولد
الجنديه السابق في الجيش الامريكي هو الذي
اغتال الرئيس الخامس والثلاثين للولايات
المتحده جون كينيدي وانه لا يوجد اي دليل
عن مؤامره محدده للاغتيال وانما تص رف
[موسيقى]
النجمه الكولومبيه شاكيرا ولاعب كره القدم
الاسبانيه جرار يعودان يتصدر الاخبار بعد
الفتره الماضيه التي كانت حافله بتطورات
المشهد بين الثنائي الشهير والذين فصل بعد
علاقه دامت 12 عاما ونجم عنها انجاب طفلين
من وقت الانفصال وكشف العلاقه التي تجمع
بين بيكي وحبيبته الجديده وحرب التصريحات
والرسائل المباشره والمبطنه لم تنتهي
والتي زادت حدتها بعد اطلاق شاكيرا
لاغنيتها الشهيره التي سخرت فيها من بيكي
وحبيبته الجديده ومن بعدها خرج بكيل يرد
بسخريه اكبر وبصوره له لاول مره مع حبيبته
الجديد ان شاكيرا خلال حفل تكريم لها في
احتفاليه
مكان اقامه شاكيرا الجديد مع اطفالها قامت
بتوجيه رساله مبطنه
وقالت انها اكتشفت ان كل امراه هي اقوى
مما تعتقد وياتي وقت في حياه كل امراه لا
تعتمد فيه على شخص ما لتحبه وستقبل نفسها
كما هي ختمت حديثها بكلمات عن الاخلاص
نشاهد مع المقاله شاكيرا
[تصفيق]
تفاعلكم لهذا اليوم شكرا لكم على كرم
المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]